- Hey, we're Rhett and Link.
- We're here at Buzzfeed and today
we're gonna be answering some questions
about our first times.
- Ooh.
(jazzy music)
I'll open it for you, make it easier.
- Okay, first AIM or AOL account name.
Oh man.
- I remember
I had one that had it was all consonants.
R-H-T-T-M-C-G-H-L-N.
- You could've said that faster.
My first AOL username was Leaky Faucet
with like three numbers after it.
- Linky faucet?
- Leaky faucet.
- Well that was a missed opportunity.
- Now I know the answer to the question,
if you could go back in time
and change anything, what would it be?
It would be my AOL username
to make it more punny.
Next question.
(jazzy music)
First big purchase as a YouTuber.
- Oh, Lambo.
- This is a funny (laughs).
So we uploaded a video to YouTube in 2006
when YouTube started.
And then I probably went
out and bought some,
I don't know, some saltines.
- You're forgetting we
bought a Scion together.
- Yeah we went in on a Scion.
- We went to the bank, we
got all the cash we had,
because--
- Literally.
We got bills.
- Because somebody told us
you need to buy in cash.
We didn't know that that meant that--
- You just paid for it.
- You just paid in full.
We literally brought an
envelope full of $18,000,
which I think is technically
illegal to carry around.
- I was gonna follow it
up at the bank teller
and say well can I have it all in ones
and can I get a briefcase?
And it still probably
wouldn't have been enough
to justify a briefcase,
more just like a lunch sack.
- Yeah it would've been annoying, too.
- First thing you do when you wake up.
- Roll over, I pick up my phone,
and build my self-image
from the YouTube comments.
- First thing I do when
I wake up is roll over,
see if Rhett's texted me
because his self-image
has been shattered by YouTube comments.
- Yep, every day.
- First time being recognized in public.
Still kinda hoping for that.
Still kinda looking around.
I frequently go up to
people and I'm like so.
(crickets chirping)
Me, my face.
Ring any bells?
(crickets chirping)
YouTube much?
- I remember a time I
was out with my family
and we ran into my grandmother.
She was like didn't expect
to see you guys here.
- But she knew it was you.
- She recognized us right off the bat.
The whole family, all of us.
- And the last one, first pet.
My first pet was a dog named Tucker.
He was brown and shaggy.
- I remember the day he died.
- Yeah, we--
- Performed a funeral for him.
- We buried him in a refrigerator
box 'cause he was huge.
It rained a lot the next
day and the whole grave
filled with mud and--
- We jumped into it.
- My first pet was Pokey, a hamster,
that got lost for a month
and we found him inside of
a sleeping bag in my closet
and he had been living off of the fibers.
- He'd been eating the sleeping bag?
- Yeah.
He lived for another year.
We're Rhett and Link, we
enjoyed answering questions
about our first time.
- Please check out our
show Good Mythical Morning,
every weekday on YouTube.
(echoing)
(jazzy music)